I extend to you on behalf of the court the
most cordial welcome
the court is meeting today to
receive a solemn undertaking from the
members of the new european commission
this is a significant moment to which the
court attaches particular importance to
this solemn undertaking  is
indeed one of the symbols of the union of law
that constitutes the European Union and to
which each of these institutions
contributes that the Registrar
I invite you to read to us
the decision of the European Council of 28
November 2019  appointing the
european commission
decision of the european council of 28
november 2019
however appointing the european commission the
european council you
treat them on the european union and in
particular its article 17 by an f3 is
also this third year to
adopt this decision
Article 1 are appointed to the
European Commission for the
period from 1 December 2010 9 to 31
October 2020 only to a qua  ity of
president or in the form of a lease
as member vice-president in
application of article and 18 by 4 of the
treaty on the european union ecb eu
i felt a high representative of
the union for the  foreign affairs and
the quality security policy of
members
messi and thierry breton linda norgrove
who worked
madame viera hulot to madame stella who
said they were going to try the smart
switches to try iran in this
profession margaritis srinath gentlemen
nicolas schmit  of its margins
certainly on itunes madam frame considers
sony but civilian worthy or getting used to it
madam to open kasika de seafrance
stimulating
madam and jutta urpilainen madam
aline nothing to try oliver barkley hard to
stop rest is left bozic
obscure article  2 this decision
enters into force on 1 December 2019
article 3 this decision is
published in the official journal of the european union
thank you sir of clerks madam
president mesda  my and gentlemen
commissioners before inviting you to
make the solemn commitment
allow me to underline in a few
words the context of the event which
brings us together today on July 16, 2019 the
european parliament on the proposal of
the european council has elected you madam  fans
of lane president of the new
commission whose mandate ran
until october 31, 2024 this same
european council has not a decision of august 5,
2019 appointed mr borrell fontelles
high representative of the european union
for foreign affairs and
security policy
on November 27, 2019
the European Parliament gave its
approval to the appointment as a
college of members of the new
commission
the decision of the European Council of
November 28, 2019, which the Registrar
has just read to us, opened the
way to the exercise by  this new
commission the plenitude of the powers with
which it is invested by virtue of the
treaties
the treaty on the functio  nment of
the European Union provides in its article
2 145 that he is a full member of the commission
during their installation
the solemn commitment to respect
during the duration of the function and after
the cessation of these the
obligations resulting from their charges
although no modality is
expressly provided for in this regard, it is
well established that this commitment
on the ol be bent before the court
carrying a double symbolism this
practice highlights is like a jelly
shoe at the opening of this
solemn hearing  the commitment to respect for the
law which characterizes the european union
and the functioning of these institutions
, the commission of which it
also underlines the importance of the tasks which the
commission is called upon to perform in
accordance with the treaty the new
college of commissioners, the coverage of which
will see  the solemn commitment in a
few moments reflects a beautiful
balance of twelve women, including the
president,
the first in history.  history of the
european union and 15 are an association
of outgoing commissioners and
new talents several former prime
ministers or ministers former
european or national parliamentarians
two other personalities from
the economic and financial world or
even former permanent
representatives to the  european union
it is a team which therefore has
all the necessary skills to
effectively meet the challenges which
the european union is currently
facing
and of which I would like to
highlight the main ones today, first
of all the results of the referendum of
23  June 2016 on the
United Kingdom's membership of the European Union has
plunged the Union into a situation which, if
it is the fruit of a democratic choice,
saddens us as
Europeans and which is completely
unprecedented in history  of
European construction
if, as everything suggests, the bric
site takes place on January 31,
the commission  we will inevitably be called upon
to play a leading role in
ensuring an orderly withdrawal from the united kingdom,
in particular by managing the
transition period provided for in the exit agreement as
well as in negotiating the nature
and content of future relations
between the union and  the United Kingdom
then actions are multiplying at all
levels local national European global
to raise awareness of the phenomenon of
climate change and its
increasingly perceptible and worrying impact,
particularly on ecosystems and
biodiversity and of course also on our
health this global movement
raising awareness goes hand in hand with the
search for a more sustainable model of society and
development that is more
sustainable in terms of the environment
and energy,
in this respect we can only be
delighted with the speed with which the
new commission has wanted to give concrete expression
to one  of its priorities
sipa the priority of its
action program I want to talk about the
presentation of  12 on 11
December, a few days after
the new college
of commissioners for the ambitious
green pact for europe took office
european green deal, which aims to
achieve carbon neutrality in the european
union by 2050
another major challenge  the management of the
migratory crisis which has affected our continent
for ten years
now,
this crisis has been one of the
major concerns of
European citizens and is fueling protest votes
and identity withdrawal reflexes
in a good number of member states, a
divisive subject if  their hands
it is also a source of
sometimes intense tensions between member states
a major challenge for the political authorities will
consist in easing these
tensions by proposing measures which, as
well as the treaty on the
functioning of the european union,
prescribes in its article 67 paragraph 2
I quote are based on solidarity
between member states and which are
fair to nationals
third countries
more recently concerns relating to
respect for the rule of law,
democracy and
fundamental rights and freedoms have emerged in
several member states and have led to
a proliferation of cases, in particular for
preliminary rulings, before the court
this  common core of values which, as you w
ite so well in your programme, madam
president, constitutes, and I quote, the h
llmark of the union cannot to
lerate any compromise or conce
sion the migration crisis and matte
s relating to the rule of law are a
ong  the main causes of
ambient euroscepticism
a challenge for the commission as well as
for all the
european institutions in the years to come
will be to emphasize even more
in communication with the citizens
the added value of the euro union
and by resorting to a  simple and
direct language this added value is so
dazzling that it should be able to
resist any form of news
or exploit  ation fundamentally ill-intentioned
the construction of
europe has transformed a continent
torn apart by wars for
centuries into a haven of peace and
prosperity in which individual rights and
freedoms as well as the
values of democracy are not reduced to em
ty concepts of pract
cal significance.  has dramatically increased
the standard of living of
citizens in each member state,
whether it is a founding member state
or a member state which has more
recently joined the European union,
moreover, a European union which
wants to be is perceived as fair must
combat and cases of tax
or social fraud such as one
contributes to concealing the
undeniable benefits that the large European market represents
for both citizens and businesses
the
economic model of Europe  fluidity and
decades of integration and
approximation of national laws
can only win support if ali's
objective of prosperity  tax fairness
and social justice
another challenge for europe is that of
the digital transition of society
the challenges posed by
information technologies raise many
delicate questions, particularly in terms
of the protection of privacy and
personal data guarantees of
security and ethics
lastly, europe is not an
isolated continent but is developing
bilateral and multilateral relations with the
rest of the world
the challenges which constitute
not only the prosperity of our
continent in the medium and long term  term but
also international peace and security
and sustainable development
we can be successfully raised
only in a constructive dialogue
with our partners
allow me to recall here all
the importance of the function of the o2
presenting the union for foreign affairs
and security policy
who is also vice-president of the
commission
introduced by the lisbon treaty
this function  on to consolidate and strengthen
those of the high representative for the
common foreign and security
policy that she replaced by
extending her powers to all
areas of external competence of
the union the issues of
economic security migration climate voice
being very often closely linked  he
expertise of the
high representative's overview is crucial to
ensure the coherence
of the union's external action
by allowing the
european union to speak with a single
voice on the  international scene
the high representative contribute to
making it a major player in the
promotion of peace and security
throughout the world, particularly with a view to the
resolution of international conflicts
all these complex and sensitive issues
ok the european commission will have to
deal with  and to which is added the fight
against inequalities of all kinds as well as
the relentless pursuit of actions
against terrorism
organized crime and the regimes responsible
for crimes against humanity and
human rights violations
call for appropriate responses in
line with the objectives of the
European project and the safeguarding of the
fundamental values underlying this project, these
responses and  i am thinking here in part
and those aimed at preserving
the rule of law and protecting
fundamental rights is a
responsibility shared by all is a
member and institutions of the union
in this context the commission has  a
major role to play in its capacity as guardian
of the treaties which empowers it to seek
from the court
the finding of a breach of state
or the imposition of sanctions in the event of
non-compliance with a court judgment
that  be it legislative or judicial,
the initiatives of the commission have a
direct impact on the
activities of the courts of the union
by broadening the material scope of the
different types of litigation.  nt
it is important to know this
illustrates the close interaction between
the missions assumed respectively by
the commission and by the
judicial bodies of the union the
commission as a
political institution promotes in all
circumstances the general interest of
the union and  the application of its finger
remake or derivatives the court as a
judicial institution is the guarantor
of independent and impartial objective justice
in the areas covered
by union law
both contribute to the achievement
of the same objectives, namely the
harmonious implementation of the various
policies of the union as well as the
consolidation of the achievements of
European construction and of the
founding values of this one madam presi
ent ladie
and gentlemen members of the commi
sion your personal qualities as we
l as your profe
sional experience and the high
responsibilities that you have been
called upon to exercise throughout your
ca  back
and laughing allow us to augur that you
will all be able to
meet the great challenges that
await you and to successfully exercise your
new responsibilities on behalf of the
court and its members, I send you
our warmest congratulations and
express the  sincere wish that your efforts
to revitalize europe and highlight
the inestimable added value that the union
represents for the citizens and
businesses of our continent will be
crowned with success i now invite
madam president and the members of
the new  commission to read the form
of the solemn undertaking provided for by the
treaties each and every one in his mother
tongue and signed the
solemn declaration will wind the ipad
for more heroes pichon rate nardine
strains of mons bottom up